on pense souvent que la vie des
célébrités est un long fleuve tranquille
après leur premier succès c'est
l'autoroute du kit avec petits fours et
champagne jusqu'à la retraite mais voilà
comme tout le monde les stars
connaissent elles aussi parfois des
moments plus délicats
même schéma pour corinne masiero si
aujourd'hui elle cartonne sur france 3
dans la peau du capitaine marc loos
cette comédienne au sang chaud a connu
des moments plus délicats dans sa vie en
rupture avec sa famille elle aurait même
sombré dans l'héroïne la découverte à 28
ans du théâtre dans une association a
été un véritable cadeau de la vie pour
moi qui ai connu la drogue la
prostitution et des années de galère
sans cette révélation jaurès sombrer
parcours inverse pour mallaury nataf
dans les années 90 avec la mode des
sitcoms à la française la jeune
comédienne se trouve une place de choix
au sein de la série le miel et les
abeilles
tout semble sourire à la jeune femme
mais après les années de succès la belle
vie de mallory tourne court et une
succession d'accidents du quotidien
l'amène dans la rue devenu sdf
elle raconte ses nuits à dormir sur des
bouches de métro à 5h30 du matin avant
que l'activité reprenne jim j'étais
debout là je marchais jusqu'à
pratiquement épuisement ménages trouver
un nouveau nom de chaleur et paf le
reprocher de son côté dany boon a lui
aussi expliqué avoir connu des moments
délicats le comédien qui est aujourd'hui
à l'abri après ses multiples succès au
cinéma a connu des débuts financier
prouvant lourdement endetté il s'est
retrouvé interdit bancaire est mis sur
les bancs de la société durant plusieurs
années et aux etats unis aussi les
superstars ne sont pas épargnés par les
périodes de crise avant le succès
sylverster stallone triplement oscarisée
pour son rôle dans rocky a même dû
vendre son chien 40 dollars devant une
épicerie pour pouvoir se nourrir des
histoires aussi étonnante que
profondément humaine qui nous rappelle
que le succès n'empêche rien de la
réalité
[Applaudissements]
serena est sheeran aussi qui a raconté
dans un livre comment il avait dormi
dans la rue et je trouve que c'est très
bien de raconter ça parce que ça montre
que tout est possible
alors ça ne réussit pas à chaque fois où
ils ont des destins exceptionnels de la
table dit la vérité ce que vous avez
peur que ça s'arrête parce que mine de
rien c'est vrai que voilà vous êtes tous
les jours à l'antenne
marianne elle sait le chemin inverse
erik arnaud toi je le dit arnaud il a
énormément bossé avant d'arriver où il
est aujourd'hui elle et rappelle même on
est même tourné un pilote genevois j'ai
tant que tout à l'heure je me souviens
j'avais fait un pilote l'ensemble ou
jeux on avait fait des caméras caméras
cachées tu devais être en voiture et hu
devaient bloquer la place de la
madeleine avec une dans une smart avec
une cape
exact c'est vrai et arnaud il a fait un
truc mais on avait tous vu tout de suite
car nos il est un très gros talons et
c'est vrai que moi ça fait non mais
voilà il n'est pas arrivé
daïna il a fait plein de choses à vendre
a galéré un port nous comme nous tous à
jouer mais c'est le parcours
c'est simple logique et normal et je
joue pour moi je trouve que c'est le
meilleur parcours parce que au moins tu
sais pourquoi at elle raconté là tu
profites moi je ne sais toujours un
énorme motif par exemple présenter ce
film indique quelles chances de voir
celui-ci après j'en ai un autre vol ah
bon c'est le film de michael bay away
mecheri évidemment j'ai à dire c'est moi
ça me plein de fois j'ai des moments
plus tard dans ce métier plus d'angoissé
simple c'est ça tape fort puis ça
s'arrête parce que tu fais des choses de
plus en plus importantes ou étudient
mais est-ce qu'un jour les gens mondiale
- l'asie mais que tu es gentil tomber ça
va c'est à vous que ça s'arrête au pas
du tout michel vraiment une peur mais
c'est plutôt un stress parce qu'il n'ya
pas de plomber quoi moi si l'émission
s'arrête j'espère que ça va tenir encore
plusieurs années mais si ça s'arrête
bon je m'empare redevenir jouables c'est
vrai que maintenant j'ai changé de vie
un homme souffrait un peu de
retravailler toute la journée
et puis voilà je me savais pas ce que je
pourrais me proposer d'autres excès hype
il faut quand même vivre et c'est donc
pour l'amour mettre de côté aujourd'hui
quand ça marche bien et devrait comme
c'est un peu chacune
dépense un peu on vous entend plus et
venez pas dangereux mais là on tiznit de
la déchéance mais déjà face à des
retraites un mélange de maille en europe
dès l'âge de 6 7 ans aujourd hui j'avais
lu l'histoire malade cette lady hamilton
cabu l'europe entre ses cuisses et qui
est morte lente et aviné à paris on me
donnait des coups de pied dans le voir
je me suis dit mais jamais ça donc j'ai
toujours adoré les histoires de
prostituées qui se range qui épousent
des bourgeois je me suis dit ça y est
elle à l'abri celle là toujours toujours
ses beautés - battu mais vous êtes jette
dans le cas du cinéma et des murphy
avait raconté qu'ils étaient payés 25
mille dollars par film et après deux
échecs consécutifs il était passé à 5
millions je sais que pour les acteurs
comme voilà comme style très compliqué
tout ce qui bouge pas je vous ne faites
que des succès mais ça ou deux échecs
des attaques au talent et sans moi
depuis le 25 millions vous paye un cours
de jeu ses retombées donc mathieu et moi
pour le coup et depuis le début et début
début de l'agent jean et qu'on ai marre
que les fossiles et ping et il ya un
monsieur qui passe et il me dit ce
garçon là il ya dix ans à son contrat
était surtout les directeurs de
programmes de deschênes 2 française qui
je dois vous dire qui mais se tassent à
la comédienne un pardon un animateur
réunit sept animateurs la ya dix ans
tous les directeurs de programme avait
son ca sa photo sur leur bureau
tellement il était à la mode c'est
aujourd'hui le mec nous raconter qu'il
allait faire des anniversaires pour
vivre et ce jour là j'ai compris que
l'antenne c'était tellement tellement
dangereux dès que j'ai gagné un euro je
l'investis pour justement me dire si en
plus je suis viré mais au delà de
l'argent est ce que vous avez peur que
ça s'arrête l'argent va évidemment
évidemment vu son ca va s'arrêter mais
bien sûr que ça va ça c'est très très
dur je pense que tous les émetteurs ddm
chose je m'en fous ya une vie après la
télé sauf que quand ça s'arrête
ils sont bouffi rouge alcoolique son
budget ouais c'est sûr 8 mai c'est
horrible et montois je m'en fous que ça
s'arrête mais se savent pas comment
c'est donc
ménard là dessus le seul truc moi qui
m'inquiète c'est vraiment cette
obsession quand je vois ce qui se passe
dans la rue avec des gens qui ont bossé
40 ans et qui se retrouvent avec mille
balles dans le seul truc qui m'obsède
c'est de me dire pendant profiter de ça
pour essayer d'arriver à la retraite en
ayant payé quelque chose à un
appartement ou une maison parce que
c'est les scènes problème il est là
c'est que les loyers sont devenus
complètement dingue et les gens qui
souffrent aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils
ont 800-900 balle de loyer donc tu peux
pas y arriver comme ça j dévoués dans
certains cas vous financièrement vous
êtes inquiet du coup pas ou des
programmes et des sucs et des
tranquillisants qui a oui et des deux
des trucs pas marché a bien sûr qu'on
aurait dû dire merci quand tu as eu
marre d'eau merci d'être là au niveau de
l'argent c'est la peur l'angoissé
émotionnel que l' aventure s'arrête
c'est très bien break une aventure comme
ça objectivement on ne résoudra pas 2 1
15 jours sans doute y aura une fin mais
le plus tard possible en tout cas parce
que quand ça s'arrêtera je crois que ça
nous montre à utiliser vraiment mais moi
aussi c'est quand même s'il sait plus
pour l'aventuré humaine
on va dire que ça ça peut s'arrêter ce
serait assez vite coup c'est vrai qu'on
vit une aventure humaine